he's the governor of the wealthiest
province in Bolivia Santa Cruz and on
Wednesday he was detained by the police
Luis Fernando Camacho is charged with
terrorism and fermenting the riots that
followed the ouster of former president
Evo Morales in 2019. Camacho was
handcuffed and flown to La Paz for
questioning
the porus took to the streets in protest
they set the local prosecutor's office
on fire insisting their governor was
kidnapped
La Paz will not turn into a jail for the
political prisoners who have defended
democracy if they detain Camacho they'll
want to detain all of the citizens of La
Paz
government supporters celebrated his
detention saying he's responsible for
the violence that took over the country
whenever Morales was forced to flee
three years ago
blood has been spilled in Bolivia this
cannot go unpunished we need to get
Justice that's why we are here the
people will not stop will keep on
demanding Justice Camacho is a high
profile leader in Santa Cruz an
opposition stronghold a former president
of Morales and now president Luis Arce
Camacho had been leading weeks of
protests over the government's delaying
carrying out Bolivia's population census
something that many believe would
benefit Santa Cruz with resources and
seats in Congress
critics say the government is using the
Judiciary to go after political
opponents so probably now we're starting
to have more opposition leaders under
threat of being detained by the
government this is the second high
profile but we have around 100
political prisoners in in Bolivia of a
kind of a low profile but now we have
two that are very very high profile
former president Anis and Camacho the
government does not agree they believe
those involved in the ousting of former
president Evo Morales need to be
investigated and judged but doing so
could increase the tension that has
plagued this Andean Nation for years